I read that DHEA is an estrogen precursor, which made me think about my last
Dutch test before cancer diagnosis. My results show that my estrogen was low,
but my DHEA was very high. For my age, does it follow then that the DHEA was not
turtied into estrogen? Well, if I have a video on the Dutch test, I'm
really sure. But let's look at what that would look like.
So here's what a Dutch test looks like. You're looking at all your hormones.
I've done a loan breakdown to progesterone. I've done a loan breakdown to DHEA. DHEA is a
hormone that's made into your adrenal gland. DHEA-S is followed. That's different than DHEA.
DHEA breaks down to DHEA-S, then testosterone, and then that can convert to these estrogen.
So the most concerning estrogen is something that drives cancer. Is this for hydroxy-esterome?
This one right down here. This is one that can damage DNA. This is the one that most commonly
attaches to the estrogen receptor on the cell membrane that can block apoptosis. Remember,
said that there's different two different apoptotic pathways. What this is blocking is the
extrinsic apoptotic pathway. So when you have estrogen receptor positive or HER2
positive cancer, it's this for hydroxy-esterome that's attaching to that receptor of the cell membrane
of the cancer cell. So it is a cause of cancer. It's just blocking apoptosis.
Now, this can build up in the cell and damage the nucleus of the cell. So anything that builds
up in the cell can be a cause of cancer. Now, you can't test for intracellular hormones.
So that's not available, but what is being tested for is whether you have estrogen positive,
estrogen receptor positive breast cancer. So it's being affected from the extrinsic apoptotic pathway.
So the question is, can excess DHEA cause a buildup of these estrogens? But what you've
mentioned, without looking at your test, this is just an example test. I just pulled out the
internet. This isn't anybody's that I know. Is that you said your estrogens were low? These are the
main estrogens that are your main functional estrogens, and then they break down into the 16-hydroxy,
4-hydroxy, 2-hydroxy, and through methylation in the CO&T gene, they break down to a methylated
estrogen-esterlone. And then your body utilizes these and gets rid of these. But if these three were low,
and this was low, but your DHEA was high, could that have been a precursor to your cancer?
And I'd say no. No, I mean, I don't think so. I mean, if this was high,
DHEA is high, typically, is a side that's part of your stress response. So, again, I'll have a video
on this, we're better understanding, but in general, your DHEA is is treated by your adrenals,
and it's part of your stress response. So, if a person is under acute stress, or even chronic stress
for a long time, they still could show elevated DHEA, chronic stress over a greater amount of time,
you ended up with adrenal, adrenal burnout, and then typically you have low DHEA and low,
low cortisol. But then that's what that first part of the first page, the back to it, of the
first page of the Dutch test also does a cortisol, you know, a sound of a very cortisol test
over time as well, you take four different samples. Now, this person is showing a depressed cortisol
level, the red is the person's, this would be the high range, so if the person's that would be under
an acute stress, they could be way up here in cortisol. Now, they're showing a very low
free cortisol, a very high metabolized cortisol, so they're metabolizing it at the very low,
free cortisol, they're under adrenal fatigue mode right here. Now, this, this one,
our here is coming with somebody completely different, so just two things I've grabbed out to you.
So, this one would show if there are a low level of DHEA, so maybe they're at the
greater, greater fatigue, but they have pretty high levels of E2 at the one at very, very high levels.
So, this is probably on the internet because it uses an example of somebody that's a great
danger of estrogen really affecting them, of course it's cancer. So, this is why a person would go
on an aerobotacin inhibitor, we try to get rid of these astrogens, this would be a person that
would probably benefit from an aerobotacin inhibitor. They got very damaging at high levels of 400
hydroxyasteroid, so they should be not at least natural aerobotacin inhibitors, but
you know, every patient of ours that I've tested, this has been, these have been really, these have
been a perfect balance because they've been taking natural aerobotacin inhibitors, so they're not
going to have the danger of attachment to that estrogen receptor. So, your question does it follow
that then the DHEA was not turning into estrogen? Yeah, it does follow that it wasn't turning into estrogen.
I would agree.